today I'll show a tiny little show with
bits of news everywhere on today's fat
man on Batman welcome back to fat man
I'm Batman I'm Kevin Smith
I'm not Kevin Smith yes he's the other
guy I'm the that is Mary mark Barnard
woman and we're here to tell you about
all the news that's fit to print so
we're gonna tell you some stuff you
probably already know but we're gonna
know it now and once we know it it is no
nice the speaker from the mountain is
smoking
speaking of which man have you been
watching Westworld I am a couple of
episodes behind on the west-world
loving it so I find no fun and if you're
a few episodes behind the episodes
you'll catch up on our a blast like it's
good time and they're doing the Lord's
work of that show but now I'm worried
they said it's coming back but it might
not be back until 2018
well that's HBO's way you know like they
come back when they're ready to remember
when The Sopranos would take like two
and a half years off between seasons and
they'd only come back for six episodes I
had to go live a real life for a while
the [ __ ] is Lou you know I'm like hey
maybe watch first in ten reruns I need
more Sopranos the it was it was just
season finale is probably not airing and
depending on when this drops it will
either just be about to air or probably
just about having this aired so maybe
we'll do a deep dive we should behave
that's my that's my spirit animal in D
and D Newton I'm not even supposed to
say spirit animals native yeah you're
baddest Patronus there you go knave is
my Patronus oh she's fantastic
and that was the storyline I honestly
thought would be the least Andy Newton
sterling least interesting to do when
it's
I was like the brothel madam who knew
that she was like the Moses of the show
the Jesus of the show yeah Harry Potter
of the show yeah so it's been great will
deep dive into into West world later on
but for now Deadpool 2 has a director
not you not Tim Miller either so long it
didn't listen to us nobody listened to
us the guy who's directing it is no
slouch himself made a movie we all know
and love called name of John wick indeed
that's right his name is David leech
leech I believe david leitch lime stunt
coordinator oh is that what I came from
yeah he and yeah John wick is a good
flick oh so much fun I put down a post
John woods good flick no more IMing I
mean it if you don't like this movie you
eat penis unless you like penis in which
case you read the other thing yeah
where's your title yeah we got this
Smith blur we're way too big hopefully
they'll recognize the image yeah dr.
Zhivago uh this guy's gettin directed
pool yes totally happy about that so you
got somebody I able-bodied beyond the
camera knows that shoot stunts and
apparently there'd be lots of that and
he's got a sense for pulp and Ryan and
the boys that wrote the first one will
be back and large in charge making jokes
absolutely so Deadpool is all it's all
right got close that art it was like an
open heart like this gem you thinking a
dead em the guy that invented the Big
Mac died today oh there was a girl who
knew that someone invented the Big Mac
but there's a gentleman in Pittsburgh
who all-beef patties special sauce
should we out of sauce special sauce
special sauce lettuce cheese pickles
onions a sesame seed bun yes
that dude put that [ __ ] again one of the
greatest advertising jingles of all time
that I'm 46 and I could still give you
the recipe of the Big Mac based on the
commercial to all beef bone oh and then
getting too much weight kiss you singing
this song on the way to this shop
considering an icon of junk food the big
man
mmm-hmm like this is you know one people
there's people like this is America and
then there are people like there's
everything wrong with them but does the
Big Mac have just two pieces of brothers
their third piece there's a third piece
of bread so that's the kind of uh oh
look at the bigness of this right the
opulence of America there's three pieces
of bread what's that guy's name somebody
look it up real quick we should give him
his proper but it wasn't like Mac
McGinnis probably not Irish no there was
a dude who had a couple franchises in
Pittsburgh and he was like you know I'd
like to do something new and they said
well you know McDonald's corporate
because they're all franchise was like
we're very happy with burgers cheese
burgers fries and shakes on the menu
don't shake it up and this guy was like
I think I could do one better and here's
what you can do you can charge twice as
much and that's what they did yeah he
made a burger that had two burgers and
his thing was like the special sauce is
gonna be all the rage a lot of people
assume it's just Thousand Island
dressing but its Thousand Island
dressing was something else his name is
Michael
Jim elegante Jim was his nickname why
didn't they call the sandwich the big
Jim no no or why didn't they call it
Mike cuz his name is Mike Big Mike Big
Mike laughs [ __ ] all Big Mike himself
a little Mike or whatever he invented
the Big Mac a sandwich which I've
enjoyed and kicked off what we have to
now call the burger arms race yeah
ergonomics if you will I mean but they
didn't kick it off no I just read this
today whopper went first did it whopper
by ten years holy [ __ ] Burger King had
the larger burger man you know
McDonald's had such market dominance so
I could say whopper we don't care I give
[ __ ] the Big Mac was the shot across the
whoppers bow that's what I read online I
would have thought yeah vice versa Big
Mac one because and whopper came later
well maybe was that's the thing like if
you're if you're Burger King you've got
to respond like you're in a losing
position you're second place you got to
do something outrageous and bold and
fattening in order to gain some more
traction you get or like are you tired
of little McDonald's burgers or the
minimum ah [ __ ] [ __ ] them right in our
[ __ ] come across the stree
to the king put a whopper in your face
right now the Kings got whopper for you
Royale with you one better
quarter pounder whoo cheese
I was shocked I thought I would have
thought whopper was the you know Oh
their visit our answer to the Big Mac
but apparently the Big Mac is the answer
to the whopper see now there's there's a
movie coming out of the end of the year
called the founder one movie I can't
wait to see with Michael Keaton as Ray
Kroc not quite the founder of McDonald's
but the dude who put the arches on it he
believed the plaques that were in all
the stores and I always stop and look
our founder and told the story of Ray
Kroc but this tells the story of the
McDonald's brothers right and how Ray
Kroc separated them from their
hamburgers mm-hmm and took it over and
put the golden arches and over 1 million
served was his idea he was a Salesman
yeah he was a shake machine salesman mmm
and he had sold a couple shake machines
to the McDonald's brothers and they kind
of hip him to like well we found a way
to make burgers this fast and he's like
this could go everywhere mm-hmm and he
became a bazillionaire but see now I
want to see the the burger Wars movie I
want to see the arms race between
whoppers and Big Macs and double
whoppers and quarter pounders and mcdlt
Burger Chef was involved but their
casualty now they're Wendy's still
hanging in there man these are [ __ ]
square R square [ __ ] we stand out we
got our red head that was their gimmick
that's it yeah and they're like we give
you square burgers that's how you
remember it
and then McDonald's was like [ __ ] it
we're gonna give you a clown who's maybe
not scary and a grimace who's what's a
[ __ ] grimace I don't know you know
burglar because crying you know grimace
isn't upside down milkshake remove the
cup you take the shake turn it upside
down that's the core so he's always in a
state of suspended animation not dying
who knew he was a shake shake you
grimace oh you're sucking off a shake
you're sucking off that monster you and
I don't want a Mel
don't know if you're the Hamburglar but
you to [ __ ] come burger oh yeah steal
my soul like we're going another way and
we like your hyper sexual version of our
character the clown isn't selling
anymore I just get porn we got to get
away from the clowns are scary
alright can I tell you my new favorite
thing do it
it is a podcast that I listened to
called my dad wrote a porno have you
ever heard this buzz great title yeah
because this dude's guy from Britain
named Jamie found out that his father
wrote a neurotic novel and so he and his
two best friends also British gay dude
and a lady read a chapter of this novel
every episode my sister and it's the
worst [ __ ] novel you've ever heard it
is so bad and this dude has to read the
thoughts coming out of his dad's head
about awful porn [ __ ] that's good it's
kind of magic so I decided when I
listened to it I imagine that it's like
Harry and Ron and Hermione finding like
James Potter's secret porn novel because
it's adorable and British and awfully
filthy I like how it's good enough but
you're like I'll make it better
what's what's your Patronus warrant
Ronis a giant [ __ ] black dildo comes
out pretty much so that is dick related
to nothing except in my favorite thing
right now
there is get a plug right there yeah Mon
porno people somebody hit me or
something something smooth hmm speaking
of smooth black panther movie is
happening yeah we all loved his
introduction in civil war I don't know
anybody who didn't love his introduction
seriously it's pretty damn badass that
movies taking shape they've just added a
major player to the Black Panther movie
telling who is Tina Turner that's right
hero it is the woman who played Tina
Turner yes Angela Bassett Angela Bassett
yourself which I remember at one time
weren't they always talking about like
she should be storm
and back in the day way way back in the
day but now she's gonna be in Black
Panther or wonder if she can play
apparently but two challahs mother
really you know share husband died in
civil war mmm yeah she's awesome minute
wasn't smoke what's she what has she
been in lately she's an American Horror
Story and she'd been directing as well
yeah yeah two challahs mama I'm big news
chopper it's so mama
big news why does that movie do 2018 I
think we do movie we're not waiting very
much longer for alien covenant yes Scott
xenomorph see no more say no more say no
more sir Ridley Scott to you and me well
with Jesus Ridley Scott who is his
brother was yesterday how old 79 years
old [ __ ] really bring chicken he's
alright he's nine years older than my
mother and he's making alien covenant
why is it my mother making at least
alien you know [ __ ] three I know for
three was good resurrection my mom
should be a resident alien resurrection
she could be making the bad alien movies
why is your mother make those movies
about aliens so bad like you know she's
trying and I'm shocked she understands
most of these concepts so bear with her
she'll get better I would rather watch
your mom's an atheist anything good
point
Prometheus was the movie where you
thought you were gonna see some
Xenomorphs yeah and you didn't really
see that many but remember they showed
us like the navigator and you're like oh
okay but apparently the space jockeys in
this one also really yeah there's a puts
on the helmet and [ __ ] and then dies in
the chair as we all did watching for me
right there that is all the hope you
need man that is strength boy that is
power the strength and power of flesh
look at the strength in your body it's
common fall silent and so what is this
the year one story of the alien you know
that's we thought Prometheus was but
unclear there's a year one story I mean
when I gonna have more and one a bunch
of him
one can only [ __ ] hope el alien had
one Ridley Scott did that and it had one
alien right Jim Cameron made it
brilliant when he was like this time we
go to we're gonna pluralize this [ __ ]
there's more than one there's two or
that were more and they were a bunch do
you see you in man think on the power
what happened in three to go to prison
planet and that was one alien inside of
her that became a dog and right and then
another does still we're back to like
one alien then Alien Resurrection was
that [ __ ] terrible alien hybrid at the
end that would just look like a master
nerds do you remember that teaser for
alien 3 that um I can remember the movie
that was on but it was only teaser but
it was like snowscape and all of this
[ __ ] and it was just like ominous voice
over and the end of it was this time
they come home and then it crests over
and you see like Anchorage or something
it was all stock footage there was
nothing that they actually shot for the
movie but there was a teaser that
threatened that the aliens were coming
to Earth well I don't they do that story
I don't [ __ ] know yeah that's next
although I think that's what this is
could be I don't remember anything about
alien V predator so I want to say that
maybe it's possible that did that but
that was bad other than just like maybe
you're not in mood for a predator movie
maybe you just want to see an alien come
to earth as you know more from him crazy
in H without a predator that just makes
it hokey and unreal yeah we only need
one kind of alien at one time that's
cool not two kinds of aliens I can't
wait man Ridley Scott controlling an
alien again the man gave you the alien
the first time mmm mmm Geiger so yeah
and maybe like is this a haunted house
movie the way alien was is it a war
movie the way aliens was let's just hope
it's not a ponderous seminar on
artificial intelligence and space travel
the way Prometheus was what about the
fencer movie
Prison movie it's a prison movie and
then for was a basketball movie
Sigourney Weaver's doing jump shots in
this movie I guess strange movie okay so
alien covenant is coming like Christmas
when does it happen next year earlier oh
yeah like March early summer comes early
let's do before less then with that
because that yeah yeah bring us down but
lin-manuel Miranda yeah the Pulitzer
prize-winner Tony winner who wrote these
songs and collaborate on the score for
the Hamilton informa wanna currently in
theaters that's right one thing he's in
a lot of things is moving venturing into
television he's not given away his shot
he's not giving away his shot yeah
really and so he's moving into TV he is
going to be an executive producer and
sort of music supervisor of this show
called
the king Killer Chronicle which is about
look just redheaded bard dude who's
telling the stories in some medieval
fantasy milieu kind of lore the Rings
but with a lot more songs really yeah
yeah oh man and so Lionsgate is has an
eye towards this as one of those
remember what what they promised us The
Dark Tower was gonna be yeah just like
we're gonna do a movie and then a season
of television then another movie and
their season television Lionsgate has
that kind of plan for this they want to
do movies on TV at the same time and
then will have a hand in almost all of
it yeah talent outs man he's insane and
he is having a run like few people have
ever had a run give them all the money's
they seem to be doing that yeah honey
just did a drunk history where he got
blasted and talked about the history of
Hamilton which is adorable is great
there's there's a moment where he's
talking about whatever like Enzo Hammond
Aaron Burr about to have a duel and then
his cellphone rings and of course the
characters not screening like Oh
Questlove was Questlove calling me
Questlove where's now
my Questlove is in the car with
Christopher Jackson who played George
Washington in Hamilton he's like I love
you guys as long as I got a job you got
a job as long as I got a job you got a
job love you you ran okay bye
drunk lin-manuel miranda is hysterical
that's genius and adorable all right
check that out yeah do that watch that
and now we end with the show with sad
news Leigh's gentleman we have to
acknowledge two massive pop-culture
deaths
let's go her first yes everybody knows
Florence Henderson even though you know
it's not quite the geek space Brady
Bunch
you know that belongs to everybody who's
ever had a television from 1970 forward
America's mom one might say as you got
to see her be the mom that you always
wished your mom was Louisville had a
generous supportive and crap like that
never those kids never got in trouble
almost not good punished never saw him
get slapped around or anything like you
know and those shows are made during the
spanking age where you can hit up a
child you totally could have taken Peter
over a knee gonna do it for if they were
like let's put that in the Brady Bunch
shut your [ __ ] pie hole why you're
single with three [ __ ] daughters in
the first place she said you're no
[ __ ] prize you are single with three
boys of your own this is the wit of the
Brady Bunch
Florence Henderson passed away sadly she
JD - I believe so
man yeah I thought she'd live forever I
thought she'd live longer than me that's
movie but all things come to connect to
an end yeah yeah TVs mom has baked her
final cake but she'll forever be
syndication yeah for everybody and maybe
her final gift to that show because
their gift to that show authorized
production was she was the comm center
of the shoe you loved her man shoes man
yeah her gift to that show probably be a
bunch of people who like oh the Brady
Bunch you haven't watched that in a
while hmm I'm sure it's one of those
shows that
and off you know ever since it's been on
the air it's been on except like this
many countries and stuff or maybe it's a
very uniquely American thing I'm not
quite sure but it for our generation
it was everything my kid chiona from the
Brady Bunch no and then neither do mine
and to a certain degree neither should
they but they were there for us and she
was my mom except for the mom that I
have no real moms who did a much better
job than our fake TV mom but she was
really yes
so Florence Henderson thank you we bid
you adieu we did you and you thank you
mom thank you Mrs Brady and and we also
lost run glass yeah this is now you talk
about TV royalty from like couple
decades right I get about Barney Miller
in the 70s and then you talking about
Firefly indeed and now you know Firefly
world I don't hoody plant fire [ __ ] he
played a character named Shepard book
who who was a man of God who had a past
that the show never actually explored
very much they kept hinting at the
reason why this man who seemed to be
pretty good with a gun who was not bad
with his hands ended up in a monastery
they alluded to the fact that he'd had
some history potentially as an assassin
potentially as a as a gun for hire who
forgo those ways and decided to follow
the path and he was the sort of
spiritual center of that show and often
in contrast with our boy Nathan Fillion
who was the sort of agnostic pragmatic
captain of the ship and so there was
always a tension between them that
eventually sort of got resolved when
when the Shepherd just said listen I
don't care what you believe it's just
important that you believe in something
and and and he was he was that rock of
that show he was you know while not the
captain he was the one that kept the
moral spheres in line and he brought
that kind of grace in that kind of
dignity to that stage that you needed
when everybody else is sort of young and
impetuous and it'll be attractive and
then you get one glass who was just this
this man of ebony rock if we can hold it
down every rock I believe is the name of
his biography that you're about penning
yes also his Keitel special every rock
super sounds of the seventies I don't
know
the Firefly but I do remember Barney
Miller
[Music]
[Music]
that's for Ron glass in the farewell
story teller fellow entertainer and
better entertainer than two of us that
was pretty good though that's not bad
right
yeah man show see my one-man show Barney
Miller that took a lot of ironically the
thing that robbed me of breath smoking
weed was the thing that gave me enough
courage to do the whole song as a you oh
it gives it it takes there it is folks
for fat man I'm Batman I've been Kevin
Smith I've been mark barnard tune in for
the next episode man the same fat Tom
same fat channel spot cast comma war
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith
you
[Music]